arnold classic everyone's required to
wear mascara i wanted to make sure you
felt comfortable yes yes thank you thank
you for that you know i opted not to but
uh it would it would definitely make me
more comfortable to be breathing into
the mask and be overheating by the way
aaron for people that don't know your
background so ceo and founder of retcon
our guys you go to your gym you know
they swear by your jam they say it's
like the church
you know it's a sick gym legit you got
to go to one of the things that he does
where everybody pushes to see who maxes
out the most bench press all this stuff
that's like 150 people though i gotta be
honest i didn't like his gym i like
being the strongest guy in the gym i was
i wasn't the strongest guy in this gym
yeah there's a beast in the gym
he doesn't like competition he's more
socialist
one of his trainers when i did the 525
press over here which none of the people
in the comments believed is real by the
way but did the 525 press at your gym
one of the guy goes uh cool man good
warm-up set and then he walks right
seriously yeah all under armour head to
toe he was like he's like i'm just
playing bro pounds it out you know your
big great comment by the way good for
him good one you know you're big when
you go to give a pound and this dude had
to get around his pec to give me the
pound okay he did the around
if you're insecure about your body
retcon's going to make you feel
uncomfortable
people are in shape yeah people aren't
shaving so tell us the story of
retconned tell us the story of ritchie
oh well i'll have to give you the fast
story but the uh the story of redcon is
uh i've been in love with sports
supplements really bodybuilding and
fitness as a kid and i was super
passionate about bodybuilding and
fitness
and um i kind of got lost along the way
and had some problems with drugs pretty
bad problems with drugs and when i
finally got out of that life basically i
thought to myself what do i love doing
at the time i was a personal trainer
yeah um this is in new orleans yeah well
in new orleans so i was i was in new
orleans uh went to baton rouge to go to
college you know i didn't go to college
that was a plan yeah anyway i became a
trainer there and then moving back to
new orleans and then hurricane katrina
happened and so i was evacuee for
hurricane katrina and on drugs at the
time and moved to houston and i was a uh
living in a fema apartment that was
provided by the government molly yeah
i'm spending all my money on on heroin
and
no electricity reading books by
candlelight for entertainment in houston
in the summer which you can imagine was
gross
and uh yeah and and i eventually got out
of that and then that's a it's a whole
long story but i got out of that through
some big cataclysmic event and when that
happened uh i thought to myself as i was
a trainer to make money that's what i
always felt back on being a personal
trainer i was pretty good at that and it
paid pretty good and didn't require a
lot of education which had none i never
went to i never finished high school
so um while i was doing uh personal
training i had a guy there that i was
really that i looked up to and he had a
porsche a new 911 turbo and what year is
this this is um
2006.
okay got it so 2006 and 911 new turbo
six yeah oh man i always love nice
things even though i never thought i'd
afford anything nice and so i went up to
him and i said man how do i get a
porsche like that it was like just like
off handcuffs yeah and he goes you'll
never get a porsche like that
and at first i was like super offended
like i'm never gonna get one you know
and uh he goes do you love personal
training and i said
i mean i like it he's like do you love
it though it was like not not really
he's like i can tell he's like i love
training people i love coming here every
day i look forward to it i write
programs at night yeah i call my clients
i you know i love it i love every minute
of it and that's why i got the porsche
that's why you won't get one and i was
like damn because if you know what a
perspective though but when he said it
how he said it it made me really feel i
felt it yeah i was like damn he's right
i'm not gonna get a porsche and uh and
so he said um think of the things that
you really really love and figure out
how to make money doing that don't be a
trainer because you don't love it and i
went home and i was real honest with
myself and took a real like mental
inventory because i was in that kind of
state of mind just coming off of drugs
feeling like where where am i going
what's the point of everything and so i
thought what is the only thing i could
think of that i loved consistently from
from 13 years old to 26 years old was
bodybuilding but as you know
bodybuilding is a genetic thing so being
a tall naturally tall skinny jewish guy
the potential to be
mr olympia or to make any kind of money
as a bodybuilder is extremely limited
super super limited and i'm sure you
also know the bodybuilders that make any
kind of money at all there's you know a
handful at most
so what's the right height five nine
five ten is that the height five eleven
is probably the really the the if you
have great genetics it's probably this
is ronnie five it was five okay
ronnie coleman's only five eleven yeah
yeah but he's seven feet tall white yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i think 511 is the ultimate height
dorian was about 511 also you know lee
haney was 511. you know that's probably
like the ideal but you have to be able
to fill it out you know and uh at six
two six three it's it's very i mean you
have to be a very special genetically
gifted person you know that was the
number one reason why i walked away from
bodybuilding too tall yeah too tall yeah
it's just
me too pretty much i mean me too i mean
i tried and i and me too yeah of course
david thanks for the plug by the way
appreciate you buddy
yeah so um so instead i realized there
is money around bodybuilding so i looked
at the sport of bodybuilding and i
looked up like people people like peter
mcguff who is the the editor-in-chief of
flex magazine you know um people like uh
truly you know joe eater obviously and
ben wieder two jewish guys from canada
so that created you know the world of
they crushed it they questioned it yeah
billions of dollars yeah um and then and
then other people uh that were
surrounding the sport that i admired uh
like dan solomon because he was doing
pro bodybuilding weekly at the time uh
bob ciccarello and these guys were
making money not a fortune by any means
no joe eater kind of fortune but i said
you know maybe i could do something like
that maybe i could write maybe i could
figure something out and so what i did
was i started um right right away
started sending articles to magazines
for free and i started posting on all
these bodybuilding forms that really
don't exist anymore now we have social
media instead of using a name like
swolegun69 i used aaron singerman in
hopes of like nobody was doing that
unless you're a problem
sean ray or something
nobody ever put their real name so i put
my name in hopes of somebody noticing
and i would post any free time i had
when i wasn't training people i would be
doing something actively to get into the
bodybuilding and fitness world and then
i did and uh we did a radio show a
podcast a hundred episodes of one called
off topic radio and that led me to start
working for dave palumbo at rx muscle
mm-hmm and from rx monster good guy by
the way yeah good guy of course he was
my boss for my last boss ever had um
and uh i worked for him worked my way up
from doing the podcast with him to
covering shows all over the world with
him to eventually taking over and being
the editor-in-chief of the site and
running all of the literally running the
business
um and during that time i had a child my
first son asher who's nine i don't think
he met asher yet what a name bro
seriously what are the chances of that
yeah you know asher like do you know the
history of asher like the the name yeah
i think so what it was what's this the
syrian name oh yes yeah yeah king asher
like asher is like a a very powerful now
i'm writing a fiction book right now the
main character's name is asher asher
yeah yeah very cool good name and uh
aidan and elijah are the three my three
beautiful names bro thank you thank you
um
we uh anyway so when asher was really
when she was pregnant with asher i
realized that i wasn't making enough
money to support a family and so for me
the dream was literally my whole life
dream at that point was to make enough
money having fun doing something i love
doing and i wasn't like aspiring to you
know buy anything fancy just had you had
gotten clean at this point yeah i've
been clean uh by the time i met dariel
i've been clean for uh a few years
so uh nothing good happened why i wasn't
clean so i was doing i was doing
intravenous heroin and cocaine and it
was like a mess like legit stuff like
that
you know hardcore stuff yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah intravenous for you know
i would do a hundred injections a day of
okay holy moly a hundred injections of
cocaine a day yeah well i was living
with a girl who sold cocaine uh so she
her uh this is a whole this is the whole
well the guy did tell you you got to do
what you love yeah i mean that was
because that was his advice
yeah so we uh i met i met a girl this is
before darielle obviously and she sold
cocaine her her boyfriend was her
boyfriend her fiance or something had
been killed in a drug deal and so she
didn't know what to do she continued
dealing with the people not the people
that killed him but the people that he
would buy from yeah and then it turned
out all the gang bangers loved her
because she's this little tiny white
girl and they didn't feel threatened by
her yeah so they love dealing with her
she can walk around bourbon street no
problem whatsoever yeah this is in
houston this isn't oh okay i gotcha you
would want a little the little girl on
bourbon street is kind of dangerous
these days um but uh unless if you're
with her yeah
525 pounds i got beads i got beads on
beats
so uh so that was the reason why she she
ended up you know being able to give it
to me for free so though we had a kind
of unlimited supply um eventually the
reason why i left and changed my life
was some a friend of ours died in the in
the in her uh apartment and we got into
this huge fight because she wanted me to
move his body and i i knew enough about
you know i watched enough
was it uh cis yeah yeah yeah i forgot i
watched enough wanted to commit a
massive felony yeah she wanted me to
move his body which you know he died
accidentally moving his body trying to
take it down to the truck and drive him
away and leave somewhere what an
appropriate uh guess right after sammy
gravada yeah this is this is very
appropriate yeah
right behind you so this hardcore man
yeah that's hardcore i mean that's
that's the literal definition of too
much of a good thing or a bad thing man
i mean how long how long were you were
you doing that for i mean that's
very lucky to be alive of course
yeah of course um i was doing like
really like the hardcore stuff for
probably
um four years or so started with
oxycontin and then you know kind of
graduated up from there yeah um and uh
really i was doing oxycontin in new
orleans but when we moved for hurricane
katrina i didn't know where to find it
anymore yeah and so i literally went to
the hood and walked around and asked for
heroin well i've heard that story so
many times so many ex-athletes so many
guys i played with you know good great
guys that you know they they were taking
percocet they were taking oxy just so
they can play they were never partying
anything like that i've talked about it
extensively and then the game's done
with you and uh you know they're just
all right see you later and you don't
get to tell your body you're not
addicted to the opiates anymore and the
next thing you know a guy who was a
first-round draft pick is mainline and
heroin out you know two two years later
you know by the way the other day i
interviewed a doctor who's a uh is a
opioid expert and he gave a ted ted talk
so i had him on
and the statistics in 2010
10 000 people died in america from
opioid you know what the numbers last
year i can't even imagine 96.
what
you had to be they locked people up with
anxiety drug addiction didn't let them
out how much of that is due to the all
the covet lockdown yeah they just lock
them in a room it's the worst even the
number in 19 was 49 000 but last year's
spike apparently was a major spike
people a lot of times one site said
seventy two thousand one sites at ninety
six thousand dollars fentanyl
and i don't know what you think about
this but a lot of the friends that i've
dealt with and a lot of people that i've
dealt with in my life that struggle with
addiction they really didn't even have a
drug problem as much as they had a
reality problem they just didn't want to
be a reality they had to escape
they couldn't get out of their past well
they had undiagnosed depression i think
a lot of us go through it but some of us
we have a different source for
escaping it some it's alcohol some it's
gambling some it's party and some it's
woman some it's pot some prayer yeah
some it's prayer but in this case it was
you know a different uh but you do see
you do see this a lot also in that if
people are able to re-channel that
addictive personality into a positive
environment
you'll work 20 hours a day when somebody
and not even think twice about that's
the thing is so being addicted to heroin
is is a constant job it's like a job
that never ends you don't have a break
because when you're either searching for
heroin you're doing heroin and then
immediately you're thinking about when
you're going to get the next heroin in
my case you know i was hustling to try
to make money to get money to buy heroin
um unfortunately i never hurt anybody or
hurt myself but you know i'm constantly
slinging this to get money for that to
buy more heroin so it's never ending you
know constant job so erin how skinny did
you get at that that four year period
were you pretty skinny or not really no
it's funny i the one consistent thing
was going to the gym
when i was really bad off my parents
always uh you didn't pay for much but
they got me a gym membership and they
always got me protein powder so until i
was doing um really cocaine you know i
wouldn't sleep for days i wasn't even
drinking water or eating anything
until i got to doing cocaine i was you
know reasonable 220 or so you were 220
on heroin yeah i didn't it didn't fit
the typical thing you know uh yeah but
then when cocaine probably like 180. got
it yeah that's still that's still big
though because the guys that i knew who
got on heroin or cocaine
i mean take the height difference it's
just they get very they just don't look
healthy at all yeah yeah but continue on
how redcon comes about so um so anyway i
was working for palumbo i was the
editor-in-chief and when uh darielle got
pregnant with asher when we got pregnant
with asher um something changed in my
mind just like when i was something
changed with the drugs and and seeing
the the body my friend and that that
ended up where jennifer was punching me
in the face and i turned around and ran
out of the apartment i never saw her
again she ended up being beaten to death
a few months later by these same guys
that she would buy drugs from holy moly
really like that not only was a wake-up
call but i was reinforced quickly after
when i found out she had been killed um
so so from that to that kind of switch
in my mind happened again when i
realized asher's coming i can't just you
know live on the minimum i have to be
able to provide and so once again i
looked around bodybuilding and found
who's making money and bodybuilding it's
sports supplements i've always loved
sports supplements i've always been into
them always taking them uh when i was
younger i thought they're the solution
to everything i always had to have the
suitable and the best you know aceto
bowl and wild muscle ticks crazy yeah
that's what i needed i thought that that
was the secret if i just had enough
metrics packets i would be like lee
haney you know
it's really an animal pack back in the
day
yeah that's really what i thought so i
was i was always into supplements in the
science of supplements and because of
all the relationships that i built along
the way with dave palumbo traveling the
entire world basically looking for you
know um the the next relationship even
though i didn't know it was going to be
i didn't realize i was networking even
though i was not working and so as soon
as i started looking around realizing
okay i can do something else i started
uh becoming more and more into marketing
and uh in understanding uh digital
advertising sales and uh google the
possibilities with facebook as they were
just becoming you know doing monetizing
facebook and so i end up becoming the uh
the marketing director for a supplement
company and that supplement company i
was there for about a year and a half
before we ended up being able to save up
enough money to start our own supplement
company and that company ended up being
the
27th of the inc fastest growing uh
privately owned companies and um through
that i met a lot of other people
celebrities like kai greene dana lynn
bailey rob bailey ct fletcher and i
started making supplement lines for them
so i would design the line i would
handle the marketing and handle the
fulfillment white label type of model or
we come up with all new formulas okay do
a whole new everything yep and uh
because most of these guys are getting
you know some of them like dana at one
point was making like four grand a month
from mhp she should be making 50 grand a
month when she was at her height of
popularity so i said very easy like hey
your your fan base is already buying all
these shirts from the company flag in
your field why don't you take that and
cross promote it you know you take those
customers where sometimes some days
they're selling 20 000 you know orders a
day on their site why would you get four
grand a month to sell somebody else's
supplements maybe make your own right i
can handle it all so i started doing
that and making other brands and uh and
then redcon1 started when the other
company i left i had a big partnership
dispute in the past company and when i
left that um i when we when i left i did
instead of non-compete i did a compete
like hey so you know signing off i'm
going to compete against you and uh and
my former partner didn't care because he
just wanted to be the boss and so when i
left i immediately started redcon1 and
the idea was to take all of the
successes of the past companies
and then you know take an honest look at
them and then you know really push those
amplify those and take a look at the the
failures and kind of remove them you
know and take an honest assessment on
what we really want to be who you really
want to stand for in supplements nobody
uh as far as i know in the history of
supplements have really decided
beforehand what are they going to stand
for who are you going to be create a
brand package you know a brand filter to
put everything through and look at
things instead of having a really
awesome ingredient really awesome
product yeah have a really awesome brand
that stands for something that people
want to support the brand not just buy
the awesome pre-workout or get a great
deal your brand attracts a lot of
military guys a lot of veterans better
persons love your brand like repton yeah
that's on purpose
yeah i would bet so in the beginning
before uh when me and eduardo and eric
hart and a few other guys said is he
military are you former millionaire no
no no okay he looks like miller
no no all right so um he looks like the
chief of staff how about that yes
um so anyway um when um when we sat down
in starting another supplement company
as you know there's thousands of
supplements yeah i mean it's a very
competitive space there's new ones
coming out all the time especially now
the minimum runs are small so because
people like if you want to be the ceo of
supplement company if you got 50 grand
we can make it for you and you're gonna
be the supplement company ceo and you'll
have your own brand right and as a
result of that you have hundreds i mean
thousands of brands every year that come
and go and uh and i realized we had to
have some differentiating factor that
was major it couldn't just be whatever
new company blah blah blah i needed to
have something a name that worked that
was catchy to a short that was memorable
that was easy to spell be able to get a
great url that was short easy to spell
ideally have it mean something
meaningful the name um obviously you
don't need that because like you know
amazon or plenty of companies just have
short name but yep um so when we were
looking for it we were looking we had
two guys we wanted to put on the team
two navy seals brandon cruz and ryan
bates these guys are the most
charismatic athletic great guys both of
them worked for steve when their senior
protection for him they had two weeks on
two weeks off and so they had time to do
it so we had this bodybuilder dallas
mcarver who was this young phenomenon
and like this stud of a guy he was a guy
that was coming up
uh he passed away about 26 years old i
don't know how old he was 26 yeah he was
a superstar i he
passed out one time uh in a posing his
body locked up and he just couldn't in
australia yeah in australia yeah he was
great is that the one where the
criticism chad nichols got for dallas
there was some kind of a yeah i don't
know who it was it's sean ray feud with
chat i don't remember there was
something that was going on that's
enough yeah i'm sure it was sean right
yeah can you guys take a minute unpack
that for me i don't know this guy this
guy died while he was posing yeah if you
can pull up his just type in dallas
mccarver dallas mcar and then he'll pull
up he was arguably arguably the the most
potential young bodybuilder in many many
many years and he was six foot two
uh and uh walked around at 365 pounds
365. his first name dallas
um
mcarver yeah he's uh
competing
competing over 300 pounds there you go
yeah
let's see if you can find a good picture
okay so i took that picture down to
images
um i mean the guy's physique he just
that's a picture that's a good one that
was one of the and towards the end there
by the way that's a 25 year old yeah 25
years old think about that
that's 25. he was 380 how did he pass
away heart heart genetic heart issue wow
yeah i didn't know we never knew but
both of his uncles his mom told us
passed away at heart attack in their 40s
so i mean i'm sure everything else
didn't help being a pro bodybuilder and
everything but you know it was
definitely a genetic thing and uh was he
pushing it too hard was he was his body
body fat too long that's the story some
people say that he was you know kind of
going above and beyond than what
everybody else was uh you know going but
you know who knows there's many
different stories to this i'm just
speculating based on what a lot of
people the truth is too that bodybuilder
is an extreme sport yeah so they're all
pushing it you know i mean every one of
them is pushing it and they all
understand that it's it's extreme sport
it's risky you know like hand gliding or
some you know it's a dangerous
sport f1 racing i've never heard it
explained that way before but that's it
really is i mean you know the body
turning you know you're you're
experimenting on yourself like a
chemistry set almost i mean and you get
something like insulin just a little bit
wrong and that's it
how big is retcon today how big in terms
of employees or revenue give me all of
it whatever you're comfortable we're in
the nine figures in revenue okay and uh
heading towards you know our evaluation
of you know close to probably about half
a billion dollars right now
amazing 250 employees and you're founder
and ceo of the company congratulations
thank you to go from that story to this
story this tells you capitals and work
and america is a great country to be
yeah what are what are 180 stories so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]